poi vi risponde comincia il video
cantando una canzone di aree di ariana
grande mentre in bocca le caramelle che
scoppiettano amico mio o amica mia amica
mia
[Musica]
perché ma perché c'è non da allora
ragazzi io io io queste cose qui io io
ho paura ammette hamelin non so cosa c'è
dentro lo faccio non so quante me ne
debba mettere in bocca però ci provo
sarà tragico ma tanto ormai c'e schifo
di ogni colore alla salute proprio
ovvero ogni uomo
[Musica]
io santissimo stai aig ma che cazzo ci
metto nista no non so se la vostra
domanda è più quella del tipo che casa
cazzo ci fa in mutande ancora scoppiarsi
roba non so se vostra domanda è più
quella del tipo cosa cazzo ci fai
mutande oppure perché fai queste cose la
risposta è non lo so è entrambe le cose
noi rata fa un caldo boia e quindi sto
in mutande ragazzi tutti i miei video vi
vedete da qua insomma d'acqua in giù
sono nudo revelations alberto scherzare
è la prima volta che mi succede però
dovevo farlo perché ogni strappo la
pelle o non lo so
tutti ragazzi sì lo so non potrà essere
più strano lì così ormai quando iniziai
blog lo so che i ragazzi prima di
cominciare come sei tori ripartire con
la fan art e la settimana che questa
settimana è stata vinta dai è stata
vinta da chiara che ha fatto questo
disegno dell'avana va bene questo è
bellissimo ma anche i baffi sexy come
pro questa ormai in dettaglio ma che
sorriso rega ha chiesto riso dell'amato
c'è questo qua copertina di vanity fair
non viventi chiaro per la farà della
settimana mi si stanno staccando i baffi
li mortacci loro e ragazzi passateli
news volevo dirvi un paio di robe che mi
avete chiesto durante questa settimana
che sono state a quanto sta allora la
prima cosa che volevo dirvi è quando
sono tornato a chi mi sono tornate a
casa in questo weekend casa mia quella
con la mia camera classica che la cosa
strana del video che mi sono schiacciato
un nuovo in testa ma tutti voi avete
detto tipo faris è tornato a casa mi
sono schiacciato nuovo in testa non so
se avete visto proprio il cazzo se ne
frega della casa mi son dovuto lavare i
capelli sette volte c'è quella sinistra
mi sembrava più [ __ ]
[Musica]
che schifo di meno vabbè o mio dio
c'è allora fermi o imbrattato cenno mia
madre mia madre mi ammazzo m no vabbè ho
bisogno di tre docce e ragazzi buona
parte di questo video lasciam perdere
alle uova grazie a dio sto per iniziare
ragazzi una serie rpg horror nuova tipo
mezza the road che non ne faccio da
secoli quindi tenetevi pronti perchè
salterà in aria tutto cose strane che
sono successe durante la settimana
allora la prima cosa strana che mi è
successo a sta settimana ma strana vera
eco mercato al ragazzo che in giro aveva
la mia maglia proprio la mia quella col
mio logo niente ci sono passato davanti
prevedere la reaction ho dovuto
assolutamente riprendere la cosa ho
appena adocchiato un tizio mano fermo ci
passo avanti e vedere che cazzo dici
passare
[Musica]
l'altra cosa strana è che tipo sono
andato a vedere un film horror tipo ieri
e tornando visto un negozio così
perché non funzioni stracazzo in negozio
non sta evocando demoni è una cosa che è
successa cosicché cassa integrazione non
va bene seriamente
istruttori verdi temi che charlie che o
avvocato la scorsa settimana e lui ha
dichiarato ragazzi detto queste
lasciando perdere spiriti malvagi che
non voglio saperne possiamo fare
risponde che me la prima domanda arriva
da gaia for forghieri come ho
pronunciato il tuo nome mi dovresti
uccidere sulla scatola dietro c'è
scritto offrirla solo carta sia si
sarebbe quella là c'è scritto o pirla
solo carta per ricordarmi che qua dentro
ci va solo la carta perché sennò ci
metto cose che non c'entrano un cazzo
quindi da quando ho scritto questa cosa
qua dentro ci metto solo carta infatti
con dentro c'è tifo carta carta i miei
baffi deodorante scrat della moglie
figlia di rum una falla autografata da
michael giorna capriccio del 66 un
deficiente 16 così mi offendo giuro che
mi offendo 16 così cruda e ti sto
aspettando in camera arrivi o no
d'accordo ragazzi con colloqui
l'episodio è stato abbastanza carino chi
era quella tipa che marin corso per
strada io ho avuto paura 9 a parti
scatti ragazzo non farmi male
vi faccio una favi domanda finale serial
a te data e ora perché una domanda seria
non succederà mai più nella vita la fai
domanda di oggi mi è mai capitato di
assistere a fenomeni paranormali sono
curioso di questa cosa perché io vado
pazzo per ste robe sempre che non mi
rincorrono tra strada prova ma fatemi
sapere ragazzi concludo che l'episodio
cosa sento seguito vi è piaciuto
lasciato commento mi piace anche la
pagina di facebook e come non divido tra
la descrizione questi scritti da ragazzi